hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video ich bin derzeit in berlin hier bei
studio 71 meinem youtube netzwerk und
hier stand noch ein bisschen fairport
von mir um die e mail zugeschickt haben
zeige ich euch das erst mal ganz kurz
wir packen jetzt einfach mal zusammen
hier das erste paket auf und da befindet
sich erst mal eine menge styropor drin
allerdings befindet sich inmitten des
ganzen styropor auch etwas unfassbares
meine damen und herren handelt nicht was
das hier ist ein stein warf mit einem
stein haben wir auch direkt weiter mit
dem zweiten verschenkt was mir zu
gewertet wurde und bei diesen dingen
hier das wurde mir nämlich von dem
feature namens ilja zugewendet das
bonding meine eltern das aufbrausen da
kann man beispielsweise auch einfach
dein gewicht zu das finde ich prima
sache die mir zu gesendet wurde mit
gewinnen moore dance factory eine
kassette die nächste sache die ich mal
bekommen habe ist diese tafel schokolade
und ihr seht vielleicht schon dass die
traum für ihn von luca und war einfach
aus dem einfachen grund weil das hat er
mir all die teuren lilly gegeben und die
meinte halt bei mir halt für dich mit
dem moment hatte ich und
draufgeschrieben wir helfen ähnlich wie
vor gefallen hat wie heißt du von luca
dachte sie kostet mit dem und nur
wollten unterschrift und hat mir aber
trotzdem die tagesschule lade gegeben
also danke an die nächste woche die mir
zu gesendet wurde ein bisschen suspekt
und war in seiner top box und wenn man
das aus praktikern wie reiswaffeln aber
mit meinem miley drauf ich weiß nicht ob
ich noch essen kann eine prepaid aber
ich werde mir auch einfach getötet
hier wird wieder andere sachen und war
auch enorm viele
wirklich meine damen und herren also wir
haben hier so was von vielen fans
einfach abgegeben wurde und durch will
hat aber jetzt gar nicht alle vier in
der kamera zeigen weil ich weiß wie die
leute wollen weil lassen doch briefe
dabei und so weiter und so fort wie das
was ich meine
die nächste sache die mir von einer
zuschauerin gegeben wurde sie wie kleine
schatulle und war es geht doch schon
noch eine kleine 24 drauf und zwar in
österreich urlaub von ihr zu weihnachten
geschenkt bekommen dass ihr partner
einfach leute leute im paket befindet
sich wieder ein stein
ich weiß nicht ob das überhaupt die
stein ist und dann münze oder irgendwie
so aber ich bin jetzt mal lieber erstmal
auf den sich um den vermissten im auge
behalten
dann würde mich auch noch unmengen an
süßigkeiten und gegen die schokolade
gummibärchen und wir wollen aufklärung
zugesagt dass sie doch
[Musik]
nach hessen colaflaschen hier ist
klingelt auch noch ok wahrscheinlichkeit
oder die tür
[Musik]
abgeschlagen die antwort was wird euch
passiert sei
sonst fragen bin ich ziemlich sicher ist
ein superheld heute sind kleine range
wie möglich
ja
im kino darf wartet ihr vom video beide
davon hält euch gefallen hat das gerne
meinen daumen hoch da dieses video für
kooperation mit studiocanal entstanden
also danke an euch für diese coole
aktion für die meisten zusammen aber es
gibt da noch am 17
der ultra coole filmpremieren wo ihr mit
mir zusammen im film sehen können oder
ihr mich treffen könnte und wenn ihr das
gewinde beugt oder einfach mit dabei
sein wollt dann findet ihr die infos
dazu in der video beschreibung dafür die
bahn wartet auch mit dem video ich
bedanke mich bei euch wird zuschauen und
wir sehen uns wieder so